[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the Fourier transform how to process
audio signals and data signals and at
this point we've been talking a lot
about the spectrogram and the Gabor
transform which is somewhere between the
information you have in a raw audio
signal and its Fourier transform okay so
if I just had a time signal maybe of
some some audio signal at some point in
time I would know exactly where I was in
time but I would not know exactly what
the frequency content is at this moment
in time
okay so I have really really fine
temporal information but almost a ton of
uncertainty in what the frequency
content is at this point in time
similarly if I Fourier transform I know
at a particular frequency I know exactly
what kind of power there is in this
frequency I know everything lots and
lots of frequency resolution but I don't
know at all at what point in time these
frequencies were being played so I have
a lot of uncertainty about the time when
these these frequency Peaks occurred
okay so here I have a lot of frequency
uncertainty here I have a lot of
temporal uncertainty and the spectrogram
this time frequency diagram is going to
give you kind of this balance of the two
it tells you what frequencies are active
at instances of time but this begs the
question can I get arbitrarily high
frequency resolution and temporal
resolution and the answer is no in this
spectrogram there's a fundamental
trade-off between how much resolution I
have in frequency versus how much
resolution I have in time I can't get
this much frequency resolution or this
much temporal resolution in the
spectrogram there's always a trade-off
and so that's really important and it
actually is related to a fundamental
property of Fourier transform palette
pairs called the uncertainty principle
so you've probably seen this before for
example in quantum mechanics the
uncertainty principle and I think it's
really interesting that this uncertainty
principle
quantum mechanics actually is a property
of fourier transform pairs in general so
this is a property anytime I Fourier
transform data there will be this this
fundamental uncertainty principle of how
much I can resolve in time versus how
much I can resolve in frequency and so
I'm going to write down what this looks
like for the Fourier transform pair so
if I have some function of time and I'm
going to actually I want to make this a
function of X because it's going to be a
little bit easier I hope you're okay
with with me making it a function of X
even though we're talking about audio
signals so if I have some function and I
compute its square weighted by x squared
and I integrate that over the entire
domain so this is integrated from
negative infinity to infinity
and this is essentially a moment of that
function this is like the second moment
of this function squared integrated and
if I multiply that so this is some
measure of my my function in space and
if I multiply that by the same measure
but of its Fourier transform so here I'm
going to integrate from negative
infinity to infinity of Omega squared F
hat of Omega magnitude squared D Omega
I'm going to multiply that this product
is always greater than or equal to a
certain small number this is always
greater than or equal to 1 over 16 pi
squared and this might not seem that
profound at first okay this is just a
mathematical fact you can derive this
this is true but what this says is that
if you try to localize where you are in
space or in time this could be space or
time whatever if I think of F as a
Gaussian that I'm trying to make tighter
and tighter and tighter okay so if I
want to make this ultra tight in space
so that I have a lot of resolution and I
know exactly where I am in space what
that says is that this
Gowan so the Fourier transform of a
Gaussian is always another Gaussian it
says that for this to be true for this
product to always be greater than this
number this Gaussian has to be pretty
spread out because this product has to
be bigger than that number so the
tighter I make my kind of peaked
distribution in space this is I mean
this goes right to the the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle the because
position and and momentum are these
these kind of these conjugate pairs
these transform pairs the tighter
my distribution in one of these
variables gets the broader the
distribution the more uncertainty I have
in my other variable and vice versa if I
have an extremely localized estimate of
my frequency if I have a really peaked
Delta function I know exactly what
frequency is active then I don't know as
much where it occurred in space or time
so let's think of this actually as a
time variable in this analogy here in
this picture I know exactly where I'm at
in time but I know almost nothing about
what my frequency content is here I know
exactly where I am in frequency I know
exactly what my frequency content is but
I don't know where it occurred in time I
have kind of maximal uncertainty in time
and this spectrogram is kind of the best
balance of the two it's the balance
where they're both kind of you know not
too skinny not too fat they're both
balanced in this this time frequency so
I still have uncertainty in time I still
have uncertainty in frequency but
they're not kind of maximally skewed
like in these two pictures here okay so
I mean I'm going over this really fast
this is a very glossy kind of shallow
treatment of an extremely profound
property of Fourier transform pairs you
always have this duality this kind of
uncertainty principle if I have really
really really fine peaked information
about my spatial distribution I have
uncertainty inherently in the Fourier
transform and vice versa
because of this uncertainty principle
this is essentially the mathematical
underpinnings of the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle and this comes up
all over the place not just in quantum
mechanics but
signal-processing all across the board
you have to be thinking about kind of
what your uncertainty limits are because
there are fundamental mathematical
limits on how much you can measure these
two quantities simultaneously okay thank
you